[Music]
welcome to meta world news
our top story why are people always
trying to steal my magic
in other news cat litter can be used to
blind people
when fighting interesting i didn't know
that
well that wraps up metal world news for
this wednesday february biscuit fountain
drink
i'm meadow world peace good night
welcome to meta world news in sports i'd
rather eat my hand
than to have my penis cut off i really
have to believe someone was going to cut
it off
but if i did i can definitely eat my
hand
i know because i had a dream where i did
it it was horrible
i ate my whole hand now that's what you
call
rhetoric well that wraps up metal world
news for this wednesday
april hurricane slip nut i'm meadow
world peace good night
[Music]
welcome to metal world news in fashion
if you woke up and there was a four inch
miniature human standing
on your chest would you swat them off i
was really challenged by this question
i would hope that i'd engage them in
conversation
but in reality i think i'd be scared of
them and swat them away
which would probably kill them well that
wraps up metal world news for this
wednesday october noise cancelling
octagon tire
i'm at the world peace good night
[Music]
did i fulfill my contract satan
welcome to metal world news our top
story ninja costumes don't come in size
xxx which is discriminatory against
enormous assassins
you know what forget about the
teleprompter
i need to speak from the heart well that
wraps up metal world news for this
wednesday may staple gun here crush
i'm mad at world peace good night
welcome to metal world news
i wish there was a
genie in here
well that wraps up metal world news for
this wednesday march hybrid ice rink
i'm meadow world peace good night
hey jim where's that genie
welcome to metal world news our top
story
the pope is thinking of moving out the
vatican so feral cats can live there
now let's go to homemaker's corner with
metal world peace
thank you meadow you need five plastic
grocery bags to make an effective
parachute
thanks meader and you will die if you
try that
well that wraps up metal world news for
this wednesday november
morning star cocktail neck i meant the
world peace
good night
[Music]
welcome to meta world news our top story
a professional athlete should never post
online
looking for people to live action role
play hunger games with them
i'm sorry gerard kaylee and zack
well that wraps up metal world news for
this wednesday august microwave witcher
i'm meta world peace good night
[Music]
welcome to metal world news in science
news it is impossible to knock yourself
out
with your own fist let's not fall behind
america
well that wraps up metal world news for
this wednesday biscuit biscuit biscuit
i'm meadow world peace good night
you win fish now i'm the one in the
aquarium
you